on sait que il y a pas de problème
mécanique sur la voiture ça c'est une
expertise qui a dit ça on sait que la
vitesse n'était pas excessive la grande
question qui se pose maintenant c'est
est-ce que le bébé est né vivant voilà
qui déterminera sa mise en examen pour
homicide involontaire ou non il y a une
expertise qui dit que oui une autre qui
est contradictoire et donc un collège
d'expert va se réunir donc je vous
annonce Cyril qu'il y en a pour au moins
2 ans d'expertise avec le procès ne se
tiendra pas avant 3 ou 4 ans parce que
ces expertises vont être très très
longues voilà d'autre part il avait reçu
un sms un message ça n'a pas influé sur
l'accident voilà c'était au moment de
l'accident aurait-il été distrait à ce
moment-là et comment ils savent pas
expertise sur
l'heure voilà l'heure à laquelle il a
reçu d'où ça venait est-ce que c'est
synchrone avec le moment de l'accident
etc et sur les carcasses de véhicule
maintenant on a des experts qui sont
extrêmement doués pour avoir toutes les
infos donc voilà quelques infos sur la
fin donc ça veut dire quoi donc là il y
aura deux expertise sur la au moins au
moins parce que le collège d'experts
pour savoir si le bébé pendant ce
temps-là il sera pas le mode contrôle
judiciaire toujours à Bordeaux où ils
continuent à sortir le week-end il est à
au CHU de Bordeaux il continue à sortir
le week-end on verra si le contrôle
judiciaire est alléger ou pas dans les
mois qui viennent mais c'est vrai que
procès pas avant au moins trois ans au
moins trois ans deux ans pour savoir si
un bébé était vivant un collège
d'experts donc il y a plein de choses à
déterminer au-delà de l'instruction sur
ce qui s'est passé exactement
voilà il y a une contradiction au niveau
des exploits d'accord donc 4 ans et puis
le premier dit qu'ils étaient le BT
était mort et l'autre on dit que non il
aurait pu vivre et puis lui a toujours
dit qu'il y avait un trou noir il s'est
pas du tout ce qui s'est passé au moment
de l'accident il y a un des deux
passagers qui dit qu'il dormait et donc
voilà le mystère pour l'instant reste
entier puisque les expertises techniques
n'ont rien donné non plus donc et c'est
fondamental parce que bébé n'est vivant
ou pas ça change il sera jugé pour
homicide involontaire ou entre
guillemets je vais dire simplement
simplement mais blessure involontaire ce
qui peut diminuer la peine donc c'est
fondamental tant que le juge n'aura pas
la certitude tant que les experts
n'auront pas déterminé il y aura pas de
procès et justement donc il va pas te
procès aussi ce que j'ai son travail
il va pas rester à l'hôpital à Bordeaux
pendant 2 ans donc pendant 2 ans il
attend minimum 2 ans là mon avis c'est
pas avant ouais
à savoir
qui a réagi c'était chez Jordan je crois
ça passera demain matin exclusivité
de parler de de cette histoire moi j'ai
pas voulu me mêler de tout ça c'est très
très triste pour tout le monde au moins
ça c'est important
pour Pierre aussi je pense que Pierre il
est puni hein il est pas près de s'en
remettre la punition elle est sévère
surtout quand on est quelqu'un qui est
censé faire rire donc là c'est très dur
pour lui c'est mais je dois dire aussi
que pour ces pauvres gens qui ont été
blessés
c'est horrible et je regrette simplement
qu'il est pas
qui n'est pas eu le déclic le déclic je
l'adore
on adore c'est la première fois que elle
réagit là-dessus elle a eu voilà elle a
à la réagi c'est assez mesuré ce qu'elle
dit c'est intelligent c'est vrai
qu'après on peut est-ce que la punition
est sévère pour Pierre Palma voilà on
peut discuter de ça mais elle pense
aussi et c'est très bien aux gens qui
sont blessés et qui ont du mal à
retrouver plus que du mal à retrouver
leur intégrité physique et mentale donc
je trouve que son témoignage est assez
équilibré en tout cas très intéressant
elle a parlé comme une copine elle a
parlé pour Pierre Palmade elle dit que
la punition est sévère moi c'est pas mon
avis moi je pense que pour l'instant il
y a pas de punition du tout et après
elle pense à la famille ça c'est bien
mais en ce moment dans les faits divers
là on n'arrête pas de voir des cartons
ou que les mecs sont sous drogue sous
alcool alors je veux pas faire la
justice moi la loin de là mais il faudra
un moment donné quand tu es sous drogue
et que tu et que tu tues un enfant ou
que tu tues quelqu'un va se pencher sur
le missile involontaire ou volontaire
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec l'alcool
le la j'ai pas fait exprès si si tu as
fait exprès un peu quand même tu as fait
un si tu t'es drogué que tu as pris la
voiture tu as fait un peu exprès quand
même j'ai un peu de mal avec ça parce
que là il a punition il pour l'instant
il y a pas de punition c'est pour ça que
le il y a pas que lui il y a pas que
Pierre Palma parce qu'il est connu il a
des projecteurs et tout il n'y a pas que
lui il y a des histoires tous les jours
où les gens font des dingrées en voiture
et il y a rien il faut penser à la
famille si ça nous arrive un jour à nous
on va péter les plombs on va péter les
plombs tu dis Benjamin il arrive une
galère avec un enfant et que tu apprends
que le mec il était comme le chef Alléno
là au feu rouge il sortait du travail ça
c'est fou c'est c'est de la folie et le
gars d'or ah les gars un moment donné il
faut faire quelque chose et cette
qualification juridique il faut revoir
au missionnaire volontaire ou volontaire
ça c'est terrible justement la peine
aussi
mais la peine en ce moment et on encourt
7 à 10 ans de prison et ils ont trois
mois avec sursis le père de Julien
Courbet il était un chauffard ivre il a
il a des débit de fuite il a eu trois
mois de prison avec sursis c'est
scandaleux mais c'est pour ça qu'on
devrait déf dans la rue bien sûr que
c'est bien d'être les pour les retraites
mais on devrait tous être scandalisé
mais beaucoup plus moi je trouve que ça
ça passera et ça on pourtant on est tous
concernés on peut tous avoir une
quelqu'un de famille comme ça je te
voilà moi je trouve que c'est c'est bien
que le débat sur la terre ça va prendre
plus de 2 ans c'est ça c'est incroyable
pourquoi deux pourquoi pas 3 pourquoi
pas 4 c'est les exercices d'accord
de la justice
le temps de l'instruction donc là on dit
2 ans mais ça peut être un an et demi
comme ça peut être trois et pourtant de
la justice
doivent attendre deux ans d'abord les
familles doivent attendre 2 ans c'est
toujours ce qui leur sort à chaque fois
quand il y a un procès moi ce qui me
choque le plus à chaque fois c'est des
projets les procès au bout de 4,5 ans
les familles disent on est en feu au
moins faire notre deuil maintenant il a
fallu 4 5 ans bien sûr le deuil
seulement maintenant au bout de 4 5 ans
là il va falloir attendre 2 3 4 ans et
pour Pierre Palmade aussi s'il a l'envie
si l'envisage de retravailler il est
plombé pendant deux trois ans il peut
pas retravailler il fait rien
mais à contrario pour répondre à Raymond
j'entends parfaitement
si infini Pierre Palmade n'est pas
condamné on se dira c'est incroyable ce
qui lui est arrivé parce que pendant
trois ans ça m'étonnerait mais il y a eu
trois ans de sa carrière brisée mais les
victimes elle elles ont une vie brisée
et d'autre part
et d'autre part quand il y a des
expertises si jamais elles sont fragiles
ou pas bien faites à ce moment-là le
procès s'achemine vers un fiasco
judiciaire et on le déplore nous-mêmes
donc moi je pense qu'il faut mieux
prendre le temps d'un collège d'experts
qui va sur deux ans déterminé
effectivement si le bébé est né vivant
ou pas viable ou pas et pour moi ça
c'est fondamental que la justice soit
bien faite je sais que c'est trop long
non non moi je dis qu'il faut pas faut
pas faire la différence entre on fait
une longue enquête une longue enquête et
on a plombé la carrière d'un mec sur de
la calomnie parce que c'était pas vrai
avec un vrai accident qui arrive pour de
vrai il y a eu un vrai choc et on l'a vu
la voiture on a tous vu il y a des le
petit garçon hôpital pour de vrai c'est
différent entre un français où on a dit
de lui attention il a fait il a fait ça
on lui a plombé sa carrière parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'au bout de 6 mois c'était
pas vrai
gouvernement va légiférer ou proposer
des initiatives là-dessus parce qu'on
peut pas rester sur le statu quo un
délire routier spécifique voilà on le
voit dans les faits divers là en ce
moment il y a plein de faits divers en
ce moment il y a une petite fille et
c'est ça c'est ça c'est pas possible on
peut pas dire sa volontaire bon bah
c'est un volontaire allez rentrer chez
vous c'est un bonus on peut pas faire ça
c'est pas possible